Ce sont ces mêmes femmes,
quand j’ai décidé de porter mon hijab,
qui m’ont soutenue.
Quand j’ai été harcelée car j’étais musulmane,
j’ai toujours eu l’impression
d’avoir une armée d’inébranlables tantes d’Afrique du Nord
derrière moi.
A 15 ans, tous les matins,
je me réveillais et me tenais devant un miroir,
j’enveloppais ma tête d’un magnifique morceau de soie éclatant
comme ma mère et ma grand-mère le faisaient.
Un jour durant cet été de 2009,
je suis sortie dans les rues de New York,
allant faire du bénévolat
dans une organisation contre la violence domestique
qu’une femme de mon quartier avait créée.
Je me souviens d’avoir senti qu’on tirait d’un coup sec.
Quelqu’un m’a attrapée
et a essayé de retirer mon hijab de ma tête.
Je me suis tournée et j’ai fait face à un homme grand, large d’épaules,
les yeux emplis de haine.
J’ai lutté et riposté
et j’ai finalement réussi à m’échapper,
à me cacher dans les toilettes de cette organisation
et j’ai pleuré et pleuré.
J’ai pensé :
« Pourquoi me déteste-t-il ?
Il ne me connaît même pas. »
Aux États-Unis, les crimes de haine envers les musulmans
ont augmenté de 1 600 % après le 11 septembre
et une femme sur quatre
souffrira d’une forme de violence sexiste.
Cela n’y paraît peut-être pas,
mais l’islamophobie et la violence envers les musulmans
sont une forme de violence sexiste,
étant donnée la visibilité des femmes musulmanes dans leurs hijabs.
Je n’étais donc pas seule
et cela m’a horrifiée.
Cela m’a poussée à vouloir agir.
J’ai voulu m’assurer que personne que j’aimais,
qu’aucune femme ne devrait ne pas se sentir en sécurité dans sa propre peau.
J’ai commencé à réfléchir à comment les femmes de mon quartier
ont pu établir des communautés pour elles
et comment elles ont pu utiliser le peu de ressources qu’elles avaient
pour offrir quelque chose.
J’ai réfléchi à ce que je pourrais potentiellement offrir
pour développer la sécurité et la force chez les femmes.
Durant ce périple,
j’ai appris quelques choses
et c’est ce que j’aimerais partager avec vous aujourd’hui : certaines leçons.
Première leçon :
commencez par ce que vous connaissez.
À l’époque, je faisais du karaté Shotokan
depuis aussi loin que je m’en souvienne
et j’avais une ceinture noire.
Alors j’ai pensé -- surprise.
(Rires)
J’ai pensé que je devrais peut-être aller dans mon quartier
et enseigner l’autodéfense aux jeunes filles.
Je suis sortie, j’ai frappé aux portes,
parlé aux dirigeants communautaires, aux parents, aux jeunes femmes
et j’ai pu obtenir gratuitement un sous-sol d’un centre communautaire
et convaincre assez de jeunes femmes de venir à mon cours.
Cela a fonctionné
car quand j’ai présenté l’idée,
la plupart des réponses ont été :
« D’accord, c’est mignon,
cette fille voilée faisant 1,55 m qui sait faire du karaté.
Sympa. »
En réalité, je suis devenue la Miyagi du Queens, de New York
à 16 ans
et, dans ce sous-sol communautaire, j’ai enseigné l’autodéfense
à des jeunes femmes de 13 ans.
Avec chaque mouvement d’autodéfense,
au cours des huit sessions de cet été-là,
nous avons commencé à concevoir la force de notre corps
et nous avons commencé à partager nos expériences
relatives à notre identité.
Il y a parfois eu des réalisations choquantes
et il y a parfois eu des larmes,
mais il y a surtout eu des rires.
J’ai fini cet été-là avec cette incroyable sororité
et j’ai commencé à me sentir plus en sécurité dans ma propre peau.
Grâce à ces femmes, nous avons continué à enseigner.
Je n’aurais jamais pensé continuer, mais nous avons continué.
Aujourd’hui, neuf ans, 17 villes,
12 pays, 760 cours
et des milliers de femmes et de filles plus tard,
j’enseigne toujours.
Ce qui a démarré comme étant un cours d’autodéfense
dans un sous-sol de centre communautaire
est maintenant une organisation communautaire internationale
développant la sécurité et la force des femmes à travers le monde :
Malikah.
(Applaudissements)
Seconde leçon :
commencez par ceux que vous connaissez.
Souvent, il peut être enthousiasmant,
surtout si vous avez une expertise
et voulez avoir de l’influence,
de descendre dans une communauté et penser avoir la recette magique.
Mais j’ai très vite appris
que, comme l’a dit l’honorable philosophe Kendrick Lamar,
il est important d’être humble et de s’asseoir.
À l’âge de 15 ans,
la seule communauté avec laquelle je pouvais travailler
était les filles de 14 ans de mon quartier
et c’est parce que nous étions amies.
En dehors de cela, j’ignorais ce que c’était d’être l’enfant
d’immigrants du Bengale à Brooklyn
ou d’être sénégalais dans le Bronx.
Mais je connaissais des jeunes femmes ayant des liens avec ces communautés
et il était remarquable qu’elles avaient déjà
ces niveaux de confiance, de conscience et de relations dans leurs communautés.
Comme ma mère et les femmes de son quartier,
elles avaient des réseaux sociaux très forts
et il s’agissait de renforcer leurs aptitudes
et de croire en la définition de la sécurité des autres femmes.
Même si j’étais instructrice d’autodéfense,
je ne pouvais pas débarquer dans une communauté
et définir la sécurité d’une autre femme
qui ne faisait pas partie de ma communauté.
C’est parce que, durant l’expansion de notre réseau,
j’ai appris que l’autodéfense n’était pas que physique.
Il s’agit en fait d’un travail émotionnel.
Nous faisions un cours d’autodéfense de 60 minutes
puis nous avions 30 minutes réservées à la discussion et la guérison.
Durant ces 30 minutes,
les femmes partageaient ce qui les avait menées au cours
mais aussi diverses expériences de la violence.
Par exemple, un jour dans un de ces cours,
une femme a commencé à parler du fait
qu’elle avait été dans une relation conjugale violente durant 30 ans.
C’était la première fois qu’elle était capable de l’articuler,
car nous avions établi ce lieu sûr pour elle.
C’est un travail fort,
mais cela n’arrive que quand nous croyons à l’action des femmes pour définir
ce à quoi ressemblent la sécurité et la force pour elles.
Troisième leçon --
la plus difficile pour moi --
le plus important dans ce travail est de commencer avec de la joie.
Quand j’ai commencé ce travail, je réagissais à une attaque haineuse,
je ne me sentais pas en sécurité, je me sentais anxieuse et bouleversée.
J’avais très peur.
C'est logique, car, si vous prenez du recul,
j’imagine que beaucoup de femmes ici peuvent s’identifier à ceci,
le sentiment accablant de ne pas être en sécurité
est bien des fois constamment avec nous.
Imaginez ceci :
rentrer chez vous tard le soir, entendre des pas derrière vous.
Vous vous demandez si vous devriez accélérer ou ralentir le pas.
Vous gardez vos clés à la main au cas où vous devriez les utiliser.
Vous dites : « Envoie un message quand tu es rentrée.
Pour te savoir en sécurité. »
Nous pensons ces mots.
Nous avons peur de poser nos verres.
Nous avons peur de parler trop ou pas assez dans une réunion.
Imaginez être une femme noire, trans, queer, latinx,
sans papiers, pauvre, immigrante
et seulement là pourrez-vous imaginer combien ce travail est accablant,
en particulier dans le contexte de la sécurité personnelle.
Cependant, quand j’ai pris du recul pour réfléchir
à ce qui m’avait amenée à faire ce travail,
j’ai réalisé que c’était en fait l’amour que j’éprouvais
pour les femmes de ma communauté.
C’était la façon dont je les voyais se rassembler,
leur capacité à bâtir l’une pour l’autre,
qui m’a incitée à continuer à faire ce travail
jour après jour.
Que je sois dans un camp de réfugiés en Jordanie,
un centre communautaire à Dallas,
ou le bureau d’une entreprise dans la Silicon Valley,
les femmes se réunissaient de façons magnifiquement magiques,
elles bâtissaient ensemble et se soutenaient
de façons qui changeaient la culture
pour autonomiser, créer plus de sécurité pour les femmes.
C’est ainsi que le changement se produit.
C’est à travers ces relations que nous avons nouées.
Nous n’enseignons pas que de l’autodéfense
mais organisons des soirées dansantes,
des repas-partage,
nous nous écrivons des mots doux
et chantons des chansons ensemble.
Il est question d’amitié
et cela s’est avéré très plaisant.
La chose sur laquelle je veux vous quitter
est l’une des principales leçons pour moi
de l’enseignement d’autodéfense durant toutes ces années :
je ne veux pas que les femmes, aussi cool que soient les mouvements d’autodéfense,
sortent et utilisent ces techniques d’autodéfense.
Je ne veux pas qu’une femme ait à désamorcer une situation violente.
Pour que ce ne soit pas le cas,
il ne devrait pas avoir de violence
et pour ne pas avoir de violence,
les systèmes et les cultures
qui permettent à cette violence d’avoir lieu doivent prendre fin.
Pour que cela arrive, nous avons besoin de tout le monde.
Je vous ai donné ma recette secrète,
maintenant c’est à vous.
Commencez avec ce que vous connaissez, commencez avec ceux que vous connaissez
et commencez avec de la joie. Mais commencez.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)